do you feel that the Veronica Mars is
going to open up a floodgate in terms of
you know more the celebrity factor the
a-list factor now coming into
crowdfunding and as you see that
happening where does that leave the
independent filmmaker um no I don't see
huge influx of celebrities i think you
know most famous people feel like that's
below me beneath me I don't want to do
that kind of thing I mean I even feel it
with just getting them into social media
in the first place I don't need to do
that you know people know me I don't
have to talk to them where they would
have a much easier time than somebody
who has no no following and starting
from the ground you know they would they
really have to struggle but no I don't
see big companies suddenly just rushing
in and and this is a totally different
business process than they're used to
they have a whole infrastructure within
their business that does nothing but
raising money and distributing money and
investing in projects and making money
that way through investment so I don't
see this as it's going to change
overnight and I know that there are some
TV shows like Firefly and that that have
said our production would be way more
expensive we couldn't do it even for
four million dollars there's two things
to that probably they're right there's a
lot of technical a lot of people
involved in that on the other side I
think some of them are going to have to
start rethinking how much budget they
really need you know how much how much
salaries are being paid and how much
really should be big vape should be
being paid how many people you have
doing kind of overlapping jobs that you
could cut I think that that the the days
of having multi million billion dollars
rushing into entertainment is shrinking
and shrinking and shrinking and we are
only just now starting to see it so
there are a lot of people who aren't
even seeing it yet but I do believe that
we will start seeing studio
infrastructure shrinking jobs being lost
this is not the time to think that your
career is going to be dependent on
getting employment there because I think
they're shedding employment and I don't
think it's coming back it's not just a
period thing when you're having films
selling for 2 99 99 cent downloads you
can't make that money up easily a 300
million dollar films and largely that is
salaries of people working those people
salaries are going to have to be reduced
that's how are you going to have to be
reduced and some of those people are not
going to be able to work there so
starting to think more like an
entrepreneur of if I'm making this and
I'm releasing this I can make money
myself is a good way to start thinking
about it now and celebrities again would
be the perfect people to be doing that
because they have something to leverage
you know that before it all crashes to
the ground get your own thing going and
there are you know people who are
starting to do that we talked about Ed
Burns but even Tom Hanks and people like
that have gone into web series to try it
out to see how does it how's this
working they have almost less to lose
than somebody who's you know putting all
their life savings and trying to get it
started because they're just sort of
dabbling and putting their toes in but
they can see you know I think this is
maybe where this stuff is going and I
shouldn't wait I should go in and get
started and start trying to shape it or
figure it out before everybody you know
finds that they have to do that so I
again I don't think that that
independent filmmakers should expect at
all to be able to raise money like a
celebrity raises money but celebrities
you know generally aren't overnight
sensations you know usually they put in
years of their talent and trying to get
discovered and having people believe in
them in the same situation is happening
with you as a filmmaker get started now
it's that no time like the present to to
start building up on that audience and
that recognition in the industry because
there's lots of ways this can pay off
for you
you